Aurore berger honoré élu yvelinoise et
présidente du groupe Renaissance a reçu
le titre de député de l'année 2022 lors
de la cérémonie des Prix du
Trombinoscope à l'Assemblée nationale ce
jeudi 16 février le jury composé de
journalistes récompense les
personnalités politiques dont le
parcours a été remarqué ces 12 derniers
mois
un peu ému pour tout vous dire qu'on a
été élu pour porter des convictions pour
les assumer et je crois que c'est ça
qu'on attend de nous et puis on attend
aussi qu'on exerce ce mandat avec
beaucoup de dignité la dignité parfois
elle s'échappe un peu elle s'évapore un
peu de l'hémicycle et c'est à nous
d'essayer de lui remettre selon les
membres du jury pugnacité et consensus
caractérise Aurore Bergé première femme
présidente du premier groupe à
l'Assemblée nationale en parallèle de sa
maternité ont été des critères de
sélection au titre les lieux politiques
succèdent à la chef de l'hémicycle
Gaëlle Braun Pivet elle aussi Illinoise
je crois que les électeurs peut-être
s'ils sont pas trompés on est lisant des
femmes qui ont je crois du caractère qui
sont plus gnasses qui sont déterminés
comme la joyeuse qui m'a remis le
résiliente en ce qui me concerne je
crois qu'en effet c'est peut-être un
qualificatif que je peux employer c'est
une manière de rendre hommage quand même
au dévouement des politiques c'est une
manière de sanctionner aussi les
résultats parce que c'est une
compétition là la politique et puis pour
moi c'est une manière aussi de montrer
qu'il y a quelque chose qui nous dépasse
tous politique et journaliste qui est la
République qui est la démocratie de
nombreuses personnalités ont été
distinguées pendant cette 31e cérémonie
des Prix du Trombinoscope Fabien Roussel
secrétaire national du Parti communiste
français a été élu révélation politique
2022 et Gabriel Attal chargé des comptes
publics séviromètre le titre de ministre
de l'année